whether you've been aware of it or not
your brain has been telling you a story
about your own life it's been telling
you a story about who you are what your
personality is like what your strengths
and weaknesses are how likely you are to
stick to certain habits and how easily
you give up on taking care of yourself
maybe it's been telling you a story
about how success and happiness are for
other people not you
you're kind of doomed to repeat your
same old mistakes you're not very good
at sticking to habits you don't really
commit to changing your life for the
better maybe the life that you thought
is the one that you wanted to live just
isn't in the cards for you maybe your
brain has been telling you that you're a
shy person or an extroverted person
maybe it's been telling you that you
suck at public speaking and you get way
too nervous and you would never do that
you could never speak in front of
thousands of people some people are
extremely aware of the fact that their
brain tells them certain stories other
people live their life kind of oblivious
to this they just think that things are
the way that they are they think the way
that they think they believe the things
that they believe and this is actually
kind of a problem for a lot of people if
you remain unaware of the fact that your
brain is constantly crafting a narrative
about your life your tendencies the
people around you and the role that you
play in the universe and we can't escape
these stories forming it's because our
subconscious is extremely perceptive
your subconscious picks up on basically
everything i've mentioned on this
channel before that over 90 of our
overall mental function is subconscious
that's kind of the consensus for
psychologists these days bottom line is
that we are constantly observing picking
up and taking note of every sight and
smell every taste and texture everything
that everyone says about you either in
front of your face or behind your back
every small success and bitter failure
is woven into this story that you tell
yourself about yourself and we believe
this story you know we kind of have no
choice we have to pick up on patterns
otherwise the world seems too chaotic
but i think the problem is that what we
think happened often isn't what actually
happened we are highly emotional
creatures we interpret things with a lot
of subjectivity and a lot of these
opinions were formed when we were so
young that we didn't even really have
the ability to think rationally you know
if your older brother decides to play
with the cool kid on the block instead
of you as the younger brother you might
feel really left out and you might think
that nobody likes you or nobody cares
about you and if a couple more
situations like this start to happen it
can really start to develop a belief
that you are not worth hanging out with
you know no one really likes you you're
not worthy of love and you'll carry that
with you subconsciously through life
having no idea that that belief is there
or why it's there but it'll serve as
sort of a fundamental character trait
woven into your story and it gets even
trickier because human beings really
like to stay consistent with this story
since it is the fundamental framework
the lens in which we view the world and
make sense of things so things don't
seem so utterly chaotic when new
information is provided to us that
contradicts that story we tend to reject
it we will throw out new information in
favor of ideas that help confirm our
cognitive bias things in line with the
story that we've always told and that
really sucks because a lot of the time a
lot of the time the stories we tell
ourselves don't serve us we might think
it serves us because we think it's the
truth because we haven't questioned it
but the proof of its efficacy is in the
pudding you know if you're not where you
want to be in life if you feel
unsatisfied on a day-to-day basis if you
don't have a sense of inner peace or
satisfaction with what you do or the
state of the world or the state of
yourself there's a good chance that your
story isn't serving you so what's the
solution well thankfully there's this
thing called neuroplasticity which is
kind of a general umbrella term that
refers to the brain's ability to modify
change and adapt both structure and
function throughout life and in response
to experience and if you think about it
this is probably the most optimistic
psychological discovery in history for
people who don't really like the way
that they behave or the thought patterns
that they tend to dive into and that's
because by introducing new stimulus or
getting new experiences or behaving in a
different way
over time can actually change the
literal structure of your brain so that
those changes become permanent you can
redesign your brain in a way that better
serves you and really the only thing
stopping you is cognitive bias and
cognitive dissonance and the fact that
to behave in a different way in a way
that isn't the way that you've always
acted it's gonna feel uncomfortable it's
gonna feel unnatural it's gonna feel
like it's not really you doing these
things but i can guarantee you that if
you do these things long enough it's not
just some sort of overused empty
platitude that these things will start
to feel more natural they will those
things will start to feel like you by
doing these things over a long period of
time your subconscious that is always
watching starts to actually develop
evidence that you are this way by acting
in this new way in the present moment
day after day eventually that present
becomes the past and when your
subconscious looks over your life you
have evidence from the past and the
present of this new behavior in this new
lifestyle and it can predict and assume
confidently that you are capable of
continuing this lifestyle and you are
capable of change going on into the
future so it all starts with awareness
it all starts by taking a step back and
trying to figure out what story your
brain is telling yourself about yourself
who are you according to you
what things do you usually do and what
behaviors do you engage in day-to-day
that reaffirms that belief and how can
you modify those behaviors to better
serve you so that when your subconscious
naturally does its thing and observes
your behavior it has some evidence to go
off of that you are indeed this new
person you are indeed the person that
you actually intentionally want to be
this time rather than the person that
you kind of ended up as by accident
since the beginning of time human beings
have used stories to help them make
sense of the world around them we are
compelled by stories when someone tells
a funny joke or when we all flock to the
movie theater to see the new spider-man
and for that reason i highly recommend
the book the science of storytelling by
will store i'm currently listening to
this gem on audible which is today's
video sponsor and it's helping me
realize that there's an actual formula
to storytelling so if you're interested
in being a more engaging speaker you
just want to tell funnier jokes at the
dinner table or maybe you want to get
into creative writing or script writing
check out this incredible audiobook and
all of the other amazing audiobooks that
you can find on audible for those of you
who don't know audible is the leading
provider of spoken word entertainment
and audiobooks all in one place if
you're into self-improvement you're
interested in productivity and
philosophy or even if you just want to
engage with inspiring and enriching
ideas that will help you grow audible is
kind of a no-brainer as an audible
member every single month you receive
one credit which you can spend on any
audiobook of your choice regardless of
cost and you also get access to a
rapidly expanding catalog of audible
originals podcasts and exclusive series
and another great thing is that once you
download an audiobook whether you paid
for it or got it for free using their
credit system you get to keep that
audiobook forever if you ever cancel
your membership you still keep your
entire library of audiobooks so if
you're interested in signing up you get
a 30-day free trial if you use my link
in the description below or just text
better ideas to 500-500 so yeah take
advantage of that link use my link in
the description below or text better
ideas to 500-500 to sign up for your
30-day free trial listen to the science
of storytelling by will store expand
your mind learn something new and as
usual have a great time
i forgot to film an outro um if you
liked this video
hit like like actually click the like
button because
it it does wonders for the algorithm i
really need the views i'm dying um
i feel loopy right now guys i've been
editing this uh video edited last uh so
we got hit by covid i got hit by kovid
pretty hard um
and we've been dealing with covet this
month so we got a last minute uh
rush at the end of this month that's why
there's two videos back to back because
i'm just working overtime here
editing this i forgot to do an outro
and
i am mentally stable very mentally
stable i'm thriving actually
um subscribe to the channel if you
haven't already
and
maybe subscribe to the second channel
yeah maybe do that
have a good one guys at this point i'm
just like cranking the watch time of
this video because i don't think this
video is long enough
um
yeah just trying to soak in that adsense
it's not awkward if you don't make it
awkward
i'm perfectly comfortable with silence
and i'm perfectly comfortable with
being cringe
i'm fully aware of the cringe levels
right now
it's cringe off the charts
some might say
is that um
oh yeah so we're at 10 minutes all right
catch you in the next video